kritik am klima paket umweltschützer und
opposition werfen der regierung vor die
pläne aufzuweichen
brennpunkt nordsyrien die usa ziehen
ihre truppen ab die türkei steht vor
einer militäroffensive wieder daheim die
leichtathleten haben mehr mit medaillen
im gepäck als vor zwei jahren darunter
die goldene von weitspringerin balaika
hamburg
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
montag an meiner seite ist für den sport
norbert lehmann einen schönen antwort
von mir
das klimaschutzpaket die bundesregierung
schon als die pläne im september
vorgestellt wurden ging es vielen nicht
weit genug
jetzt hat das umweltministerium im
internet den gesetzentwurf dazu
veröffentlicht und der bringt
klimaschützer und opposition auf die
barrikaden weil er ihrer meinung nach
noch einmal abgeschwächt wurde
es geht vor allem um drei punkte für
2040 wird kein nationales ziel zur co2
einsparung mehr definiert das
versprechen die bundesrepublik werde bis
2050 überhaupt keine klimaschädlichen
treibhausgase mehr ausstoßen ist nicht
mehr verbindlich festgeschrieben und es
will nun offenbar doch kein jährliches
gutachten des klimarats geben das die
wirksamkeit der maßnahmen überprüft
patrizia wieder meyer noch ist es ein
entwurf noch wird an der endgültigen
fassung für das klimaschutzgesetz
gearbeitet
umweltschützer und opposition fürchten
jedoch eine abschwächung durch die union
für ärger sorgt derzeit dieser vom
umweltministerium veröffentlichte
entwurf wonach das ziel bis 2050
klimaneutral zu werden nicht mehr
versprochen nur noch verfolgt wird auch
die jährliche überwachung durch eine
expertenkommission sei nicht mehr
enthalten
beispielsweise ist der klimarat der das
ganze überprüfen sollte deutlich
geschwächt worden
der bundestag hat nicht mehr die
möglichkeit selber gesetze an zu
schärfen wenn ziele nicht erreicht sind
und vor allem fehlt eine verbindlichkeit
die dann auch sanktioniert wäre
klare worte daraufhin heute von der
kanzlerin bei der eröffnung der
sogenannten klima arena in sinsheim
diese überwachung wird glasklar in dem
klimaschutz gesetz verankert sein und
ansonsten werde ich nicht zulassen dass
wir das verabschieden von abschwächung
könne keine rede sein betonte auch der
staatssekretär im
bundesumweltministerium
in diesem klimaschutz gesetzentwurf gibt
es nichts gibt es nichts was die
klimaschutzvereinbarungen in irgendeiner
weise abschwächt doch die forderungen
nach änderungen beim klima paket bleiben
aus der wirtschaft ebenso wie von der
mittelstandsvereinigung der union die
deutsche klimafrage wird nicht an den
deutschen fleischtheken oder in den
deutschen heizungskellern entschieden
sondern weltweit und deswegen brauchen
wir vielmehr bezug nach europa ja den
globalen bezug und zwar
sektorübergreifend und dieser punkt
sollte mehr mittelpunkt stehen am
mittwoch soll das klimaschutzprogramm
voraussichtlich vom kabinett
verabschiedet werden wenn man sich bis
dahin geeinigt hat während die einen
über ein gesetz streiten gehen die
anderen auf die straße die britische
bewegung extension rebellion auf deutsch
etwa aufstand gegen das aussterben hat
weltweit zu protesten aufgerufen und zu
zivilem ungehorsam
es gab blockaden und festnahmen in
berlin blieb es friedlich stefanie rein
berichtet
der potsdamer platz in berlin gegen
mittag blockiert die aktivisten von
extension rebellion wollen radikal für
die umwelt aber gewaltfrei für
klimaschutz demonstrieren sein so dass
es nur noch über zivilen ungehorsam geht
der öffentlichkeit zu schaffen bzw
die verabschiedung von passenden
notwendigen gesetzen zu erwirken
sie fordern dass die bundesregierung den
klima notstand ausruft dass deutschland
bereits 2025 klimaneutral wird und dass
bürgerversammlungen in klimafragen mit
entscheidend sonst wäre die zukunft
düster
innerhalb der folgenden generationen
keinerlei möglichkeit geben zum
derzeitigen klima zurückzukehren und
extrem viele spezies auf der erde werden
aussterben
die hälfte der erdoberfläche könnte
unbewohnbar sein
in großbritannien wo die bewegung ihren
anfang nahmen legen die aktivisten heute
teile des londoner verkehrslärm es gibt
festnahmen auch in amsterdam werden nach
blockadeaktionen demonstranten
festgenommen
in berlin bisher keine zwischenfälle
also ich würde das jetzt noch nicht
überschätzen momentan weil die
dynamisierung ich meine frau des future
hat mit einem kleinen zivilen ungehorsam
angefangen dass man nämlich nicht in die
schule geht jetzt momentan sieht das
hier doch noch sehr friedlich aus
extension rebellion die rebellion gegen
das aussterben will noch die ganze woche
in berlin aktiv sein
dem bürgerkriegsland syrien droht ein
neuer konflikt die usa ziehen ihre
truppen aus dem norden des landes ab
jeden moment könnte die türkei dort ihre
angekündigte militäroffensive starten
was international große sorge auslöst un
eu und auch die bundesregierung warnen
vor fatalen folgen vor allem für die
zivilbevölkerung
um zu verstehen was dort gerade passiert
hilft zunächst ein blick zurück als der
terrorgruppe islamischer staat teile des
landes beherrschte christoph testerin
2014 der es auf dem höhepunkt der macht
von nordsyrien bis weit in den irak
reicht sein gebiet 2015 die usa
beschließen dass terror kalifat muss
bekämpft werden
aber wie ohne bodentruppen die
amerikaner verbünden sich mit kurdischen
gruppe
in nordsyrien beliefern sie mit waffen
2015 bis 2017
so ausgestattet erobern die kämpfer eine
igs hochburg nach der anderen nimmt
viele der terroristen gefangen 2018 zur
unterstützung der kurden stationieren
die usa rund 2000 eigene soldaten in
nordsyrien all das direkt an der grenze
zur türkei
die sieht in den immer stärker werdenden
kurden ein riesenproblem befürchtet
deren kampf um unabhängigkeit und damit
auch terror im eigenen land januar 2008
zehn türkische soldaten vertreiben
kurdische kämpfer aus dem grenzgebiet
westlich des östlich des flusses können
sie das nicht wegen der dort
stationierten us-truppen genau das
ändert sich gerade
die usa ziehen ihre soldaten ab nicht
zuletzt auf drängen der türkei
die kurden sind ab jetzt auf sich
alleine gestellt dass die usa ihre
soldaten abziehen wird massiv kritisiert
auch als verrat an den kurden bezeichnet
angesichts dieser kritik hat us
präsident kommt jetzt der türkei via
twitter gedroht ihre wirtschaft zu
zerstören wenn sie irgend etwas
unternimmt was er zitat in seiner
unvergleichlichen weisheit für tabu
halte thomas gill über einen konflikt
mit unberechenbaren ausgang am morgen
ziehen die usa ihre ersten
militärkolonnen aus syrien ab die
amerikaner räumen zwei stellung direkt
an der türkischen grenze
präsident erdogan bestätigt den abzug
der usa lässt aber offen wann seine
truppen in die umkämpfte grenzregion
einmarschieren wollen diesen videos wir
hatten immer gesagt dass wir eines
nachts kommen werden wir werden die
bedrohungen der terror-organisation
gegen unser land nicht länger
akzeptieren
die überraschende kehrtwende der usa
macht den weg frei für die von ankara
geplante offensive gegen die bewaffneten
kurden das ziel erdogan will im
nordosten syriens eine sogenannte
sicherheitszone einrichten hier sollen
bis zu zwei millionen syrische
flüchtlinge aus der türkei angesiedelt
werden
durch den abzug der amerikaner stehen
die kurden jetzt allein
bislang waren sie in der region amerikas
verbündete im kampf gegen den
sogenannten islamisch
start sie kontrollieren auch die
gefangenenlager in dem die es
terroristen sind die kurdisch geführten
milizen stünden für den kampf bereit ist
es auf der internetseite der syrisch
demokratischen kräfte sdf kommt die
invasion werden wir uns verteidigen
die mehrheitlich kurdische bevölkerung
protestiert gegen den abzug der
us-truppen es besteht die gefahr dass
die kurden die lager mit den es
terroristen nicht mehr kontrollieren
können
präsident trump verteidigte seine
rückzugspläne auf twitter jetzt ist es
zeit für uns aus diesen lächerlichen
endlosen kriegen viele nur
stammeskrieger auszusteigen und unsere
soldaten nach hause zu bringen
in der nacht hatte die türkische armee
zusätzliche panzer und artillerie in die
nähe der syrischen grenze gebracht und
ihre geschütze richtung syrien
ausgerichtet unser korrespondent für die
region ist uli gack im moment in bagdad
uli was passiert wenn die türkei
tatsächlich in syrien einmarschiert
damit sicherheit eine große humanitäre
katastrophe wie wir sie in anderen
ställen eben auch in diesem konflikt
schon erlebt haben es wird nicht die
letzte das letzte drama sein aber mit
sicherheit ein sehr großes heute
nachmittag hat die türkische luftwaffe
die stellungen der kurdischen
arbeiterpartei im nordirak bombardiert
das ist ein zeichen signal
möglicherweise dass diese operation
unmittelbar bevorsteht nicht vielleicht
heute nacht vielleicht nicht morgen aber
richtung wochenende gewiss die tür die
kunden selbst die reden von einem
dolchstoß man hätte sie missbraucht im
kampf gegen us und lässt sie jetzt
fallen von amerikanischer seite der
frust ist unendlich die chance gegen die
türkei zu bestehen haben die kunden
letztendlich nicht in kothen ard die
kunden haben ihre guerilla die türkei
hat ihre luftwaffe letztendlich wird es
aussehen wie in weiten teilen syriens
auch verheerte landschaft verbrannte
erde in endlose züge von flüchtlingen
die türkei selbst will diesen konflikt
offensichtlich durchziehen
da gibt es keinen zweifel die frage ist
in der tat was passiert mit diesen gs
kämpfern verschwinden sie tauchen sie
unter
und ein anderer stelle wieder auf die
quoten haben schon lange erklärt auf
diese leute nicht mehr aufpassen zu
können
das szenario dass hier kommt
möglicherweise ist in jedem fall grausig
die einschätzung unseres korrespondenten
uli gack vielen dank auf ihrer flucht
richtung europa sind wieder menschen
gestorben bei einem busunglück vor der
italienischen insel lampedusa sind laut
küstenwache mindestens 13 migranten
ertrunken alles und frauen 22
flüchtlinge konnten gerettet und an land
gebracht werden nach weiteren
überlebenden wird gesucht insgesamt
sollen rund 50 menschen an bord gewesen
sein als das überfüllte boot kenterte
zur bundeswehr
die beteiligt sich aktuell weltweit an
13 einsätzen die meisten davon auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent dazu gehören
standorte am horn von afrika im sudan
und südsudan in der westsahara und in
mali auch dort bildet die bundeswehr
sicherheitskräfte aus um langfristig den
frieden zu sichern sowie hoffen besuch
bekamen die soldaten in der nähe der
hauptstadt bamako heute von ihrer neuen
chefin annegret kramp karrenbauer
andreas ruppert war dabei hier im
trainingslager in colli coro schult die
bundeswehr gemeinsam mit 22 anderen
nationen im rahmen einer eu-mission
einheimische soldaten
wenn man sieht wo wir vor fünf jahren
angefangen haben und wo er mittlerweile
sind kann man glaube ich eine gute
steigerung und verbesserung der manchen
streitkräfte feststellen
genau über diese entwicklungen will sich
die deutsche verteidigungsministerin bei
ihrem truppenbesuch informieren sie sich
ein bild der lage machen denn die
situation in mali ist fragil wie es die
militärs nennen während der süden
relativ sicher es wird im norden und dem
landesinneren gekämpft islamische
terroristen bekommen dort immer stärker
zulauf ich glaube wir können feststellen
dass wir doch unseren beitrag auch
einigermaßen zur stabilisierung
beitragen ansonsten wäre die situation
sicherlich schwieriger
und das ist etwas das man immer mit
bedenken muss das bundeswehr-mandat für
die ausbildungsmission in mali läuft im
nächsten frühjahr aus dann muss im
bundestag entschieden werden wie und ob
es überhaupt weitergeht
die deutsche verteidigungsministerium
kommt in einer zeit nach mali in der das
land immer unsicherer wird für die
bundeswehr mission bedeutet dass ein
längerfristiges engagement
dennoch ist die malische armee alleine
nicht in der lage das land vor terror zu
schützen
folgende nachricht hat uns vor wenigen
minuten erreicht im hessischen limburg
ist ein mann mit einem lkw auf mehrere
fahrzeuge aufgefahren
möglicherweise absichtlich eine person
wurde schwer verletzt rund ein dutzend
weitere leicht der mann wurde
festgenommen wie zellen auf eine
veränderung des sauerstoffgehalts im
körper reagieren
das wusste lange niemand drei forscher
haben diese frage beantwortet und
bekommen dafür den medizin nobelpreis
die entdeckungen der us amerikaner greg
sie menzer und william kerlin und des
briten peter radcliffe ermöglichen neue
therapien gegen krebs und blutarmut nach
einschätzung der jury haben die forscher
entdeckt wie sich zellen auch in großer
höhe vor den folgen von sauerstoffmangel
schützen
30 jahre ist daher der mauerfall das
jahr 1989 steht für den anfang vom ende
der ddr
in unserer reihe 30 jahre friedliche
revolution blicken wir noch einmal
zurück auf die wichtigsten ereignisse
dieses jahres am 17 oktober feierte das
sed-regime den vierzigsten jahrestag der
ddr zu besuch kam auch der sowjetische
staatschef gorbatschow andreas postel
erinnert viel zu feiern gab es nicht
mehr zum republikgeburtstag in der ddr
heute vor 30 jahren guten abend verehrte
zuschauer ich begrüße sie zur heute
sendung 40 jahre ddr im mittelpunkt der
offiziellen feiern zum stadtjubiläum
stand heute die militär parade in
ost-berlin die sed staats und
parteiführung feiert an diesem 17
oktober trotz demonstrationen und
massenflucht die das land erschüttern
die militärkapelle spielt dazu wie auf
der titanic michail gorbatschow
prominenter geburtstagsgast aus der
sowjetunion vector gegen hoffnungen auf
reformen
ich glaube gefahren war nur alpine die
nicht auf das lied reagieren erich
honecker fühlt sich von gorbatschow
verraten gelassen hast und perestroika
offenheit und umgestaltung kommen
sed-politbüro nicht an
gorbi gorbi woche dagegen auf der straße
während am abend im palast der republik
gefeiert wird formiert sich draußen der
protest gegen die sed-herrschaft es wird
der letzte ddr geburtstag gewesen sein
zurück ins jetzt zum sport norbert da
sind die die deutsche leichtathletik
nationalmannschaft ist zurück aus
zuvor gab es ja gestern abend sozusagen
noch den krönenden abschluss mit dem
weitsprung sieg von balaika hamburg
insgesamt sechs medaillen für das team
zweimal gold und viermal bronze eine
etwas bessere bilanz als vor zwei jahren
in london
fröhlicher empfang für die athleten
heute mittag am frankfurter flughafen
den star der deutschen mannschaft
suchten die fans bei der ankunft in
frankfurt vergeblich malaika me hamburg
zog es vor von doha aus nach thailand zu
fliegen vier wochen lang abtauchen stadt
weit springen der perfekte sprung die
erste deutsche weltmeisterin seit heike
drechsler 1993 und nur noch 18
zentimeter hinter deren deutschen rekord
ein ziel für die neue überfliegerin
siebenmeter 30 und 1 bei einer wm noch
nie da gewesener vorsprung von 38
zentimeter auf die zweite es war der tag
der 25 jährigen studentin ein neuer star
der deutschen leichtathletik zehn monate
vor den olympischen spielen von tokio
große personalsorgen in der deutschen
fußball-nationalmannschaft beim
testspiel gegen argentinien am mittwoch
muss bundestrainer löw inzwischen auf
zehn spieler verzichten und hat deshalb
heute den freiburger robin koch und den
hoffenheimer sebastian rudy
nachnominiert die morgen zum team in
dortmund stoßen löw gehen die spieler
aus doch trotz der vielen absagen hat er
ausgeschlossen mats hummels
zurückzuholen
durch die personal not rücken die
neulinge serdar vom fc schalke und amiri
aus leverkusen in den blickpunkt die
ausfall serie wird auch beim training
sichtbar
es ist eine überschaubare gruppe die am
frühen abend übte zumal mit werner und
gündogan zwei weitere an
geschlagene profis fehlten das ist
natürlich keine gute voraussetzungen wir
machen es besser draußen möchte auch
nicht lamentieren ist auch manchmal eine
chance für andere spieler für junge
spieler dann aber es ist im moment schon
auch mal ungewöhnlich hart für uns löw
hofft dass der personelle notstand sich
nicht weiter verschärft vor dem test
gegen argentinien das auch schon
probiert was unser land nicht
lamentieren
zum schluss noch ein hauch von frivolem
paris die berühmteste bühne der welt
feiert geburtstag
das hat 130 jahre auf dem buckel und das
wird entsprechend zelebriert 12 hoch das
bein von altersmüdigkeit keine spur die
damen tanzen zur feier des tages auch
vor dem welt berufen variete das erlebt
selbst er ist eben eher trübe sind die
wetteraussichten hier es bleibt
regnerisch wo es chancen auf etwas sonne
gibt sagt ihn gleich christa stirb claus
kleber begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn
im heute-journal wir danken für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und wünschen ihnen noch
einen entspannten abend bis morgen denn
sie müssen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
gegen abend heute gab es das
zwischenhoch jennifer aber ab jetzt
übernehmen wieder die regen ausläufer
von tief peter und die kommen heute
nacht schon im nordwesten an morgen früh
die ganzflächige regen von der eifel bis
zur lübecker bucht bei einem frischen
südlichen wird wenn es nicht nebel gibt
gibt es die wolkenlücken am ehesten im
osten und südosten muss dann aber auch
wieder abkühlt das wird nicht ganz so
kalt wie heute morgen aber null grad
sind in der osthälfte wieder möglich
unter den wolken im westen bleibt es bei
sieben bis zwölf grad morgen ist es ein
ticken milder tagsüber als heute nur im
osten 11 bis 13 sonst aber meist 14 bis
19 grad sogar am oberrhein
denn der frische böge südwestlicher wind
bringt kurz mal mildere luft wer aber
sonst kommt das regenband weiter voran
bis zur mitte dahinter also im norden
nimmt das ganze in wechselhaften schauer
charakter an und lässt auch nachmittags
nach aber hierüber der mitte verstärkt
sich der regen ab dem mittag noch mal
und zwar von rheinland pfalz und dem
saarland her
nur südlich der donau bleibt es wohl
anfangs trocken aber nachmittags und
abends kommt der regen auch hier an der
am mittwoch dann am alpenrand noch mal
einiges an niederschlag bringt und auch
sonst geht es windig und wechselhaft
weiter was für uns regen bilanz
allerdings nicht das schlechteste ist